house to go that's my spirit and welcome
to so it's Sunday and I realize I
haven't made a Friday video so I wanted
to make a quick set noise you boys here
line what is it coming from so I do I
didn't have anything to make today so I
wanted to make a video and show I knew a
girl boy little puck his name is Edgar
Edgar Allen after the poet so his name
is Edgar Allen Poe hahaha his favorite
hobby is poetry in twerking isn't that
right Edgar he's about one year old
Edgar demands a lot of attention and he
was very nervous in our new home and he
wouldn't let us sleep and it was just
insane and I can't even believe I've
been able to make videos this week
because Edgar is so crazy but I'm glad
we kept him because he's growing on me
and such a sweet pug we have another pug
as you know in the video and she's
actually in Italy right now and she's
coming in a week gosh so boring shut up
already
so this is your new brother Edgar Maya I
can't wait to meet you or whatever um I
really weird a little of Edgar he's so
chill right now he's usually crazy cuz
you're [ __ ] talking all the time
hey can I have a kiss Junior's not on
camera what are you doing come on just
one kiss no whatever you boring me oh
you have a look
[ __ ] are you doing much you don't like
me I'm trying to teach him how to
destroy barrels but we're starting with
football go Edgar yes that's right yeah
Edgar what are you doing oh [ __ ] my
nipple Edgar oh no no no enough no no oh
you're disgusting
[Music]
I'm sorry I didn't have anything else
planned today I just want to make a
video showing Edgar off you're gonna see
a lot more Edgar in two videos in the
future so yeah I promise next week I'll
do a more interesting Friday or whatever
let me do it a bronze account are you
sure yeah I'm ready
all right whatever Brother star whatever
you know did I do it good whatever I
don't care
[Music]
you
[Music]